I have my personal passion about how
companies work what make them tick what
make them have the next decision and the
bad decision what really led me to do
how can we give anyone in the company
any employee have access to Reliable
accurate and organized data that can
help him generate his next decision that
was delivered the most Ry the best
Hawaii
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with alad sad dog the CEO and co-founder
of tagado a company that collects
customer feedback about companies and
transforms them into business insights
using natural language processing their
platform allows companies to organize
customer feedback from multiple channels
and generate actionable business
insights automatically it gathers public
and internal information from review
sites social media support tickets CRM
and more and uses models of natural
language processing and machine learning
to identify Trends and micro Trends
opportunities and risks and flood them
to the customer he was the VP at product
at Brazil meter which Google Acquired
and also founded gadgety the largest
tech website in Israel in February of
2021 he founded tagado with Ellie and
Dole
I'm really excited to have you here and
talking about a subject that I I'm so
excited about natural language
processing another subject that I'm
really kind of sure about is customer
feedback and being able to build
beautiful products and the integration
of the two through to takadu your is
your your company which I'm really
excited to learn more about it because
it just looks it looks awesome it looks
you know so relevant to today and you
know just recently Chad GPD was released
which I'm sure you've already spent half
of your working day playing with because
it's just so freaking awesome and then
and so it's a lot of things are
happening with NLP but at first I want
to understand a little bit about
yourself your relationship with natural
language processing and natural language
processing and with
um with the customer feedback on the
other end tell me a little bit about you
know yourself in the context of these
two
sure so I was the VP product at the
company called prismeter that was
acquired let me Google a couple of
months ago and during this time period
there was a lot of the first employees
and during this time for almost six
years I was handling all the products in
the company and one of them made and
challenges that I had is every time
every cycle in a robot cycle when I was
looking to understand what does she do
next what will benefit our customers and
give them the most value I had to go
around the company and ask differently
Partners about what might talks for them
and how they think we should improve the
product and service to our customers so
what happened did I discover that a lot
of this data is locked inside decent
silos in the company so there was some
data some customer feedback in the
marketing department and some of the
sale of the customer success of support
and some even in the in the product
department and I had to go to each and
every Department and ask them for their
insights and what they their perspective
on how we can we sell the customers best
and how we can improve the product such
as a tedious process that could take a
few weeks to really build the roadmap
around really listening to the customer
and the prop the main problem was that
the data wasn't twitchable to everybody
so I had to go to department and get
this data by doing it by pull instead of
getting it by push
yeah it was a new challenge and
I think that this is the main thing that
led me to take a do also I have my
personal passion about how companies
work what make them tick what make them
have the next decision of the bad
decision unfortunately during the time
evaluating the idea of tagadu we learned
that a lot of a lot of companies
speaking about customer experience and
customer Simplicity but very no amount
of companies really doing it because
it's so challenging because of those
stylings that are spread across the
organization and Veterans character
across the organization and this is what
really led me to do how can we give
anyone at the company any employee have
access to Reliable accurate and
organized data that can help him
generate his next decision that will
deliver the most Roi the best Hawaii
all right so let's talk for a second
about this idea of bringing this to
every employee right I mean
traditionally when we're talking about
this customer feedback there are
specific personas that are most relevant
in in assessing on caring about customer
feedback why did you you know what what
is it behind the the statement every
employee it's an important state thank
you
yeah so I like to use a sentence that is
full of buzzwords that I usually tend to
and to say it we tried to
revolutionizing the decision-making
process by democratizing customer
feedback so the goal is to bring the
customer voice to any decision it can be
a marketing decision when you need to
write to the right content only to to
create the right knowledge for your
customers or product marketing to help
them understand what the users have
challenging with if it's product that
needs to evaluate different feature
requests all different product
equivalents if it's customer experience
teams or customer support team that can
better improve the performance by
creating pre-advents answers to to many
questions that customers have and
everything usually is a line around the
customer we need to bring in the best
experience we need to bring in all hairs
of course the best product but this is
how I got as the company because by
doing so we increase the attention we
increase engagement and we reduce chair
so listen is something it's very
important it's extremely hard because
this data when it comes in a
in a combination of thousands of reviews
from online or Facebook posts or Twitter
tweets or even Zs tickets or intercom
chess there is a lot of data a lot of
interaction points in the customers and
all of these data sets uh is the same
time that they are locking different
departments they are also very hard to
analyze so take it to really streamline
the process first to aggregate all data
together organize it to the relevant
topics that are relevant for the
specific buildings we are working with
and then on top of it generated insights
so you can really listen to your
customers without having the huge data
scientist team or business or product
analyst team and just getting
qualitative data like you never had
before before with we're making the
quantitative quantitative and the
resulting is very hard to consume in
most cases
incredible let's let's transition to
talking a little bit about the
productization of it and I think that
the question of productizing NLP is a is
a really interesting one at that and
because at the end what we have here is
you know a phenomenal you know set of
Technologies or a set of tools and where
we need to integrate them into a way
that through user experience where the
people are able to enjoy them tell me a
little bit about what your key
understandings are for natural language
processing as a user experience
perspective and then how you're bringing
that to the product of tagadu
yeah so that's a great question I think
I added a bit of the unique road to that
point and first thing is that into
isometer we did a lot of predictive
algorithms and machine learning to
really predict and in that case and
predictive quality arrival but I didn't
have the correct touch with specifically
nmp and and then when I met one of my
co-founders care was a fast experienced
in NLP was a media to Citibank in that
aspect and then I learned from him the
different Technologies and capabilities
how can we utilize nrt to solve certain
problems and on top of that we we
thought about how can we build an
end-to-end m and Ops let's say a
solution that we have the application it
is defrauded but on the back end we
built a lot of infrastructure from being
able to understand on the Fly what are
the correct topics for each company how
can you can clustering all the different
data sets to have coherent story about
those topics how can we measure the
accuracy except the most accurate for
each type of customer so for example if
we would like to understand if the user
is talking about a bugger contain
compared to a user is complaining about
pricing Wheels different models because
it's different complexity of
understanding of what's the protein and
I think other unique approaches that we
have a wide range of let's say let's
call them Universal topics that we can
use them across many companies such as
feature requests and bad complaints
question user challenges and we
collaborate we we combine those with
dedicated topics to the company and then
the combination of those we can
understand okay you are the bug in this
specific feature your feature request
in this specific aspect of the of the
product so we utilize different
Technologies and different technology
methodologies to really gain those
in-depth insights and on top of this we
built our product that is really easy to
use and it really enables everybody to
quickly understand in five minutes watch
the opportunities and risks that we can
highlight in Italian automatically for
the users about what representatives and
risks in the customers feedback so about
in this in the check-in can be a huge
risk for a company because even if only
five percent of the users complain about
in five percent Revenue so there's a lot
of things that combinations of different
aspects of the business and how we can
minimize those risks and identify those
opportunities as soon as possible so you
can engage those with the customer
improve that and deliver as quick as
possible and of course increase your
main kpis to beneficial users and
increase the value
and and and how does a product actually
work you know streamlined into the
day-to-day of the different functions so
how you know if we're looking at
different functions working in different
companies walk me through some of the
use cases of how these different
functions will experience the product
sure so
we know nowadays that each building says
quite a few of public and in Terminal
customer interaction channels
um through which they receive feedback
continuously so it can come from any
point of contact in the company it can
range from Facebook groups to send us
tickets every company has an ecosystem
of customer physics LLC but
unfortunately in most cases this process
presentation is not good so if I am a
product manager that would like to
understand how can an improve a feature
that are responsible to be or how can I
improve a certain product that I mean
the own evolved I can log in quickly to
take Ado look for this specific product
or this specific feature and see
immediately what people are saying about
it in different aspects what features
they would like me to add about they are
compelling about or even six data
sometimes didn't even consider measuring
so when you add an it with quantitative
data you are deciding in Advance what
you would like to measure tiger do
because it's qualitative data will help
you building new processes on what you
should do next what is the next step
that you should click in it can be
applicable for any position if you're in
product marketing you know when I was
product manager and my managers used to
tell me that you don't need to develop
all the time you can sometimes send them
different situations without developing
some stuff so in many cases you can
create better knowledge if you have a
product marketing department we have a
knowledge Gap over here maybe we can
create a tutorial maybe we can create a
blog post that we can help people
understand this feature while product in
right away and we don't need to reinvent
all of our UI to improve it so it can be
handled through different departments
and the accessibility for the data
really accelerate this process we're
gonna can really easily login and see
and understand what's going on with the
customers and it's the company getting
bigger the distance between different
departments is getting larger also so
when you are 10 employee startups you're
talking all the time and you understand
what was the customer and you all have a
gut feeling about what's going on but
when you're ready to 48 1700 200
suddenly your q18 is very far from the
customer and they're getting tasks
covered from above on top down for what
process every problem in that aspect but
they can't really understand what's the
context and with stuff you do we enable
different employees to have the complete
context of what they should do and I
think this is something that we hadn't
cherish in tagado and giving this aspect
to a business
and what's happening results awesome
it's really uh I'm really excited to see
you know both with tagadu and in general
how this industry evolves because it's
uh you know we're such a the in the in
the in initial steps of everything
that's happening and there's so many
exciting things that are that are going
on and you're just talking about you
know one of those things that sound it
really does sound exciting from a
technological perspective how do you see
you know sort of the world evolve with
NLP from you know the foundation models
that we have NLP as a service by
companies like open ai ai 21 Labs
fine-tuning models for specific use
cases like the ones you're mentioning
how do you see this world evolve
yeah so one thing that I usually try to
remember is that NLP or machine learning
is not metric but we need to make it
feel like one so it's not magic it's
Advanced algorithms the note of
automatics that generate those different
things that will try to prove a note on
it but it's not magic it's a lot of
artwork and we need to make it feel like
a magic
um but in the specific aspect in the
approach of Davido we chose a
multi-modal approach so in some and also
it's very cost effective so in some
cases it would like to classify
something or understand certain topics
from data we could use different models
that can generate close to the same
results and but with being cost
effective cost effective on the server
side or on the servicing so on the
server side we usually work on Amazon
foreign
but on the setting side there are
services such as GPT open AI scores and
other different solutions so we always
try to evaluate what's the best model
to any specific scenario and we do
anything on the slide when trying to
understand our accuracy for topic
detection so when I have a specific
feedback and I would like to understand
what are the specific topics that are
relevant in each and every feedback I
can use a specific topic detection for
bug that is usually a more complex model
more a natural NLP oriented model but in
some cases I can use regular statistical
models and on top of that and use
settlement analysis so for example when
you're trying to identify when someone
is talking about price it's usually tend
to to be pretty easy to understand when
someone is talking about price if it's
positive or negative but when it's
something that should require more
context awareness such as the Bible
feature requests or even if someone
asking a question then we use more
advanced models but in some cases we
started winning the dense models but we
tried and we see the results and we get
on the Fly accuracy of different models
you can understand okay maybe we don't
need something so complex we can use
someone starting to do bit and bless the
resource in Tennessee then we can be way
more cost effective and also deliver
much quicker the onboarding process
intercedure it's up to two weeks and
it's usually a very complex compared to
multiple additional customer experience
platforms that usually take up between
three months to six months I think this
process that we built around utilizing
different NLP models and different
Technologies enables us to be really
critical delivery and of course
brilliant results
very very cool and I can I can see how
how convicted you are about about this
and how it sounds like it sounds really
really great and uh coming from a little
bit from this industry to and it sounds
like a really really cool thought
process tell me a little bit about why
you know why do you do what you do so
you were breezometer very very cool
company got to interview the CEO for the
show as well
um you know why why going to this route
why open a new company why go into NLP
customer service
customers feedback
so I I think I I would touch a bit on my
personal story on that end so I left
Brazil majority of the peak so it's a
company allowed investing a lot of time
there I thought about a video for like
one two years but I fell in love with
the entrepreneurs
and we had a great connection ever with
chemistry but I felt that I need to go
out and start my own thing using wisdom
balance things I I decided to do that
and and at that time like a month after
Corona outbreak started so it's a very
interesting point of time to building a
business and but the the main idea I
claim from my experience from prison
meter but this it took a better a bit of
a step back so I think the first
um Step that led into that was the
category it's a website that I
established in 2008 it's a tech Hills
website that we covered technology and
Gadget and one of the last genius right
now we're not imagining it and not
imagining it anymore but the battle with
this car key handling it and and then I
learned that I'm really not understand
upcoming book and how they are deciding
all the next steps and positionally on
much larger companies and sometimes
things didn't fit in the strategy that I
perceived from the company and I felt
the same when I worked with lisometer I
the benefit to work with a lot of larger
devices and I had I had the privilege to
work with those companies and help them
improve their products and the third
part of the mission before is meeting
early my co-founder and that is an
expert in NLP and this is where my
passion was built At All by us that
opened and oh we can utilize new
technologies to really optimize and
streamline this process of from customer
feedback to meaningful product and based
decisions in real record time and not
putting so much effort because you're
going to companies and you suddenly see
that the customer success team or the
customer experience team have a
quarterly almost the report about our
customers and the engagement and then
feedback and it doesn't make sense it
should be in real time like you're
working with Google analytics you're
getting in real time and so we believe
that it should be the same for the for
the customers experience part of the
business and it's new it's something
that we are the in many cases without
the first point of touch for those
companies with those Technologies with
these Technologies
and he's very excited to read it yeah
and I think the main passion was
recorded in blizzometer I got a lot of
respect from the co-founders and Muslim
Liberties so rather than the team that
you mentioned the CEO please Dominator
used to tell me that you're the rules
you're the rules of the company you're
the one that everybody's cut into State
everything was going on with all the
capitals and all the complaints and with
the development and everything so I said
okay why am I the only one how can I
make anybody in the company be a rules
and this is exactly what led me to
takadu I would like to give the power to
anybody in the company to understand in
few minutes
um what's going on in the company with
the customer respect and really help
everybody make the right decisions and
have the correct motivation around it
and keep everybody in line and it's
mainly from my experience and for my
co-founders experience so everybody
everyone brought his own aspect so and
though was a team leader in early SVP so
in different aspects we found that we
had struggles understand the context of
tasks in the context of the machine
events and the vision that we have and
really takadu was was the was the thing
that enables us giving those
capabilities and to empower the
different place to do so
thank you so much for an amazing
conversation best of luck with with
tagadu sounds awesome
um it's crazy what's happening here and
it's so many different amazing things
happening the world of NLP and their
intersection with Humanity that I'm just
wrapping my head around it and so I
really appreciate the time that you
provided here and the energy and I look
forward to cheering from the side and
again thank you for everything
Mr Black thank you very much Michael it
was a pleasure to be on the show thank
you
[Music]